hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play unfair Mario
okay so you guys have been suggesting it
like a lot of the games and I have a
feeling this is a lot like cat Mario
another game I hate I want to be the guy
goddamn so I'm probably gonna be in it
for the long haul to die over and over
and over and over and over now over now
an hour an hour an hour and over again
but let's go okay oh that's a good boy
everything goes red one death Oh what Oh
fu that wasn't even there before okay
alright so we're off to a rough start
I'm gonna go to a rough finish pass no I
refuse I was right though wasn't it was
probably to crush my head like a walnut
Oh yup I knew it you free control oh
there's gonna be good I can feel it in
my bones I'm gonna love this game
bypass under these ones okay checkpoint
maybe ah the checkpoint was real okay
ah oh it's gonna be good I can already
tell I need to warm up for this cuz I I
just woke up like 30 minutes ago so I
need like stretch out get my anger
checked okay all right here we go
okay checkpoint
jump on the first one okay I'm not gonna
lose it this time because me being
markiplier the utmost professional when
I play these games Oh what was that all
about
okay alright keep going keep going come
on Zim just get through this with speed
and precision speed and precision why
that that wasn't even them trying to get
me that was me being stupid hotels going
on my camera's off - I don't know what's
going on
God dang it dingus man oh boy oh oh oh
oh really oh really Zappa you wanna play
oh is that all you are doing Bogart
oh come on haha I got a life to live
this isn't fair to me I might have a
family someday
oh good oh good
how do I even get past this one I don't
even know hawk I hope you guys don't
like EBSCO don't mind obscenities I'm
spinning on my screen Jonna I was okay
give me that time
Oh God now watch out for nope ah watch
out for nope watch out oh you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh okay the bridge is
fine yeah don't fall it oh [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's horrifying
much like the namesake of the game this
doesn't seem to be fair this isn't right
why do I have to go through these things
for your entertainment
I wanna I didn't even wanna play this
game okay so what do I do here do I go
back
oh I didn't even touch it I didn't even
touch it
okay I just guys versus calmly like
happily you know don't mind death but
okay my god it's just a magical
adventure oh you can't get me mr. Wong
ah fine no okay I'm okay because I am a
professional gamer professional gamer
and entertainer I would not compromise
the integrity of the game by being angry
at live my mind and then I might lose my
job and then imma move out of the
country and blame blame it on the
commies damn commies take it away from
everything
- go okay so let's try there there's no
thank you go it's like nowhere I could
go Carrie
dime Isaac target uh nothing helping
maybe you go there oh gosh showed off
the guns ha
only 36 deaths it seems like I've been
doing this forever know what's wrong
with me
rod me ah pass okay I I can do this okay
just got take it calmly
I'm professionally oh not the first step
Oh Oh gimme okay I did not know that was
gonna happen
it's all one big booby trap how far can
I go here get sick of that music yet I
am
I'm a baby cross for my mommy baby oh
man oh that's okay ketchup on top of
that brick and then I can jump off of it
to my death I wasn't even now fifty does
yeah and not even fair
maybe that's why it's called that shut
up just shut up
ha ha key talking oj oj i said what
hey okay get over there okay
let's just carry on I try to get it good
go backwards oh no I can make that no I
want it it was so badly I was too bad no
my crew you owe 62 - don't okay I just I
just want to throw my own death keep
give me something that I could control
ah what noble what's the point of doing
double its insult me as you murder me
god damn Mario I feel bad how many
shrooms did you take to get enough lives
to go this is what you all wanted to see
me reduce to a weeping baby of a man a
broken shell with nothing left to live
for
everything taken from him a man on that
so that actually does fall down good I
was wondering about that glad we sorted
that out oh oh I'm gonna I forgot
god dammit darling balls Tollan collar
when Legler morton could lawfully check
the footage rewind a bit
I wasn't oh you son of a [ __ ]
that was a Dickies dick move I've ever
seen no huh oh man I hope you guys
weren't looking for a good play through
this this is awful this is awful of
multiple levels this making me hate my
life
I just hate my life I give up I give up
saying that I wasn't even there cuz this
game doesn't care oh so good maybe I can
make it maybe I actually can make it go
god I can make it no I'm done I'm done
I'm done I'm done I'm done okay
hey dick dust is enough I'm done done
are done okay so thank you so much for
watching
never suggest me another game to play
over again so take this video shove it
up the creator's ass and good go look at
some puppies and kittens or something
god damnit okay so thank you everybody
so much watching clicking annotation for
more videos it I've done link to play it
is in the description below if you want
fun of yourself so thank you again as
always I will see you in the next video